so I got to start with the most
important question well first let me
start with I just want to say thank you
because I really appreciate you guys and
what you do and uh you know the work
that you do I just want to say thanks
because I really enjoy it that's nice
thank you very much so do we so being in
an apple movie does that mean you get
Apple products for free for like the
rest of your life no I hope so no it's
not but you can't you tell it to them
this is what I'm talking about now very
good money for a movie but they will not
give you an iPhone I I thought at the
party last night we were all gonna get
new iPhones but that didn't happen no
right so I have plenty questions to ask
about your movie and I want to say
congratulations on it but um I like
throwing some curveballs at the
beginning so if someone has never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why was the first thing I want them
to watch is taxi driver I'm not in that
but but they should watch it because
then they'll understand where I'm coming
from
sure good answer it all started with a
Great Escape for me the Great Escape I
it was my favorite film as a kid right I
was actually thinking your resumes but I
I see the way you diverted
he wasn't a taxi driver
when you are playing a character that
really gets into your skin how long
after a shoot does it take for you to
let go of the character you're playing
it depends sometimes it's um you know on
your walk to the trailer after the last
shot and sometimes it's months later it
depends it depends on what they've meant
to you how how much
um have fun you've become of them how
what your experience was like making the
movie you know they're not all like this
no I was telling you and that I remember
the last time I took off my costume
playing John Brown I was in real pain
about it you know I I didn't want to
finish playing the character I just
loved him so much and it took uh months
for me to really kind of
let go
oh
unbelievable performance I'm so glad you
feel I loved it so much I was like whoa
but then there's other times where it is
true where sometimes you don't like the
experience or sometimes there's aspects
of the character that bring out aspects
of you that you don't enjoy they're not
something you enjoy going to so those
you're very quick to let go of and with
this
I I it had been a long time since one
was such an easy fit that it was like I
I there's aspects of Ray that I see in
myself and seeing other characters I've
played so I felt really comfortable in
the skin of this character jumping into
this film actually uh the the thing that
I was thinking about when the movie
ended was how how the talking drama is a
genre that is like dying on the vine
it's so hard to make these movies and
like this used to be the staple of
studios for so long and now thank you to
Apple and streamers and whatever this
came along
um can you sort of talk about that that
like this movie is is it's not um you
know it's not a superhero movie it's not
what you know what I mean it's almost
analog in a way exactly like there's no
CGI it's two brothers just talk it's a
lot of talking it's a story it's a story
about people and there there are still
people writing stories about people but
it's true that they're not
um
they're harder to get made they're
harder to get seen like last night
seeing this film in such a huge screen
here at Tiff was such a treat you know
it was a treat and you don't know how
many people will go to see dramas like
this in the in the cinema anymore but it
doesn't matter I still exist on on out
there as a story that people will be
moved by and I recently saw a Revival of
some Arthur Miller play and I remember
thinking does anyone even try to write
like this anymore like does anyone try
to write the Great American play you
feel Arthur Miller trying to capture all
of humanity in this two and a half hour
stretch you know and I I respect the
hubris of it you know the the quality
the the
striving for excellence I I really
admire and I do this is the kind of
movie that made me want to be an actor
but they are I was sick that before the
before Trilogy is a great example the
first Before Sunrise was made with a
studio the second one nine years later
was made with Warner independent like an
ancillary and the third one was
independently financed those kinds of
movies just people talking and people
being with each other are getting
ushered out of the mainstream
conversation that's what I was basically
trying to say but I did it ineloquently
or because I can't speak English no I
get I get what you're saying it's it's a
it's a mystery to me I don't know
because I I still feel that people want
to write these and and
as often as not we still read them
whether they end up getting made or not
I still get sent scripts like this you
know but they're they're never they're
rarely of this quality because Rodrigo's
such an amazing writer but still still I
read scripts about people in real life
situations and
but if they're not really excellent they
don't get married yeah and even if they
are excellent yeah or they don't get
seen in the center yeah yeah I think the
reason people are going to watch this
and being honest the reason I wanted to
see this is because the two of you are
in it I mean that was immediately like
oh please I I want to see this
immediately you know because of mine
well but I mean I I think I represent a
lot of people out there because they're
fans of your work I'm so I am curious
though you for for both of you
um you get offered a lot of scripts when
you've worked with Rodrigo before but
yeah what was it about this the
character and this story that said I I
absolutely have to do this I just
thought it was such a a beautiful
exploration of
it was an unusual story it's a very
unusual story are you reading it you're
going what what and then the exploration
of somebody's
pain and the fact that this character
Raymond appealed to me immediately as I
could I could understand and see
how men or humans bury their pain away
you know and then try and control the
world in a sort of rigid
rulesy way in order to just get through
life and then because of the Brother Ray
who just unpicks and just forces him to
let that anger out in order to live and
and be in the world in a better way I
find that I just find that so moving I I
sort of related to it in a way that I I
can't explain why I don't have to
experience myself you know it's the
stuff of real life our real life is
driven by our relationships to our
spouses our lovers our parents our
friends our children so when somebody
can make art about what's really going
on in our life you know I find it really
exciting
um I'm so curious I could never learn
lie I can't learn lines and I'm and I
love asking this of actors I hope you
don't mind
um how do you actually prepare the night
before you're getting ready for this
shoot where you know it's dialogue are
you you know before the shoot begins are
you learning at all are you learning it
on the weekends before for that weeks
how how do you do you remember my
grandmother when she would come see a
place
yeah well the actors all did a good job
nobody forgot their love
it's really the easiest part of what we
do it I I okay go on sorry I didn't mean
to do it oh it's just it's funny that
people
it's like uh
it's like anything in life it's a habit
you know when you have strong habits
this is I've been doing this since I was
13 years old memorizing things you know
I can memorize things pretty quickly I I
am scared of when I hear older actors
talk about when it starts to go you know
I mean I mean some actors that are way
better than me I mean there's you hear
stories about these
you know Billy Bob Thornton or something
he could read something once doesn't
matter if it's you know a monologue he
reads it once and can pretty much repeat
it back to you
I can't do that but I can't do that even
yeah
yeah it's it's yeah it's like you say
it's it's it's the imagining of the it's
the it's the thoughts behind it's not
just the words it's the there's the
journey you're you're remembering the
path of the feelings and the thoughts
and and the words sort of fall into
place yeah when you really are
meditating on why your character speaks
and what is motivating him to speak then
there were memoring of the lines is easy
but you're trying to figure out is why
you're saying them and what's driving
the impulse to say them and if the thing
is Well written then the lines happen
all by themselves when you were sent to
script were did you know the character
you were playing because I was wondering
as it ended if what it would look like
if you had played each other's character
yeah
I I I read it Rodrigo sent me the script
first because we worked together before
and we're friends and he was able to
just give it to me
and and he sort of let me choose I
suppose but I I I had no doubt I wanted
to play Raymond it wasn't really a
question to me at all I don't I don't
know why it just appealed to me more of
that character and then I read it that
way and it just seemed exactly right
yeah it seemed right I'm assuming that
and I don't know if it was like that on
this shoot but I would imagine when
you're filming something there is a day
in the schedule that maybe you Circle
because you know it might be emotionally
challenging or it's a big action set
piece or whatever it may be you know
it's going to be a tough day
um was there one of those days on this
shoot and if so what was that scene or
day I think the moment they break that
for me the moment I was leading towards
the moment where Raymond unleashes his
rage where he finally Taps into his
anger and lets it out and allows himself
to be truly
rageful at his father for what he did to
him and and the the whole movie for me
is for Raymond is building up to that
moment and then there's more movie after
that which was fun to play but that day
was it's the same same for both of us
it's his unraveling that breaks Rey and
provokes the playing at the grave so
it's really it's our fine each of our
final goodbyes to our father I think was
the day that was circled from the
calendar
um I have an individual question for
each of you if you don't mind
um what is it like voicing uh Batman on
on bat Wheels I believe that's what it's
called well you know it's just a kids
show sure but it's still voicing Batman
wow you know
you know the things we said yes to
during the pandemic are very interesting
no I I have a I have a lot of kids and
I've spent a lot of my life really
grateful to people making good kids
entertainment of how you spend those
mornings when uh you don't want to get
up or you're making coffee and put in so
I I enjoyed I enjoyed it it was a little
foray into making some entertainment for
kids and my individual question I've
mentioned it before we started I am so
looking forward to Guillermo's take on
Pinocchio what was it like being a part
of that project yeah it's wonderful to
work with him he's he's a character and
somebody I liked for a very very long
time admired his work and it was it was
great to do they're they're a little
solitary you know voicing animations of
any kind you tend to do the work on your
own uh as opposed to like with other
actors so it becomes more sort of mild
picking away with like working on each
line but um
it's fun to have seen it come together
over the year they've been shooting it
for four years like stop stop for an
animation four years and um
to see over the time I've been working
on it from from a cartoon drawing to the
finished animation which looks
absolutely beautiful it's been it's been
wonderful to see that I really cannot
wait to see them yeah we're on the same
page on that note I want to say a
sincere congratulations on this film you
guys did such great work and thank you
for your time